on sait pas un sondage alors justement
c'est la dernière chose que je voulais
aborder avec vous ce soir dans les
émissions que l'on fait sur les
municipales vous poser souvent la
question y aura-t-il une abstention
importante alors selon une étude ifop
dévoilé lundi matin 28% des français
envisagent de ne pas se rendre aux urnes
à cause du coronavirus alors pour
l'instant ça ne remet pas en cause un
l'organisation du scrutin christophe
castaner l'a rappelé ce matin dans des
termes assez voisin à skis à ce qu'il
avait tenus il ya quelques jours en
coûte il n'y a aucune raison médicale
qui justifierait que nous considérions
cela comme un rassemblement dans le
bureau de vote et qui justifient
justement ce report
sur ces bases un certain nombre de
préconisations d'organisation doit être
mis en place et nous travaillons avec
les associations d'élus pour définir ses
modalités de bon déroulement de vote
sonné il a raison castanet sur ce point
non mais c'est absurde de dire il ya
deux raisons médicales puis on a tout à
fait dit que oui il y avait des raisons
médicales
non ce qui est intéressant de savoir
c'est si ça va impacter le voit tout pas
voilà c'est la question que pose et
caroline alors oui si si tout le monde
s'est tu sembles pas de la même façon
les seniors qui sont les zones les plus
exposées au virus ont plus tendance à
aller voter que les jeunes les citadins
les cannes et à paris justement beaucoup
de gens ne vont pas voter
parmi ces jeunes citadins ses cadres
donc ça peut avoir un impact fut
finalement sur le résultat des sondages
et de toute façon il ya beaucoup
d'abstention pour les élections
municipales
oui elle est le vote tel que la victoire
se fait à quelques voix du coup c'est
une élection quand même généralement par
exemple ont simplement un point me oui
mais quand même là pour ça woody 28%
vont s'abstenir si un dernier quart à
vie alors écoutons là ce que les 28
s'ajoute aussi c'est bon on voudrait
savoir lequel est le plus difficile à
prévoir en matière de sondages de
politique c'est l'abstention sur les
votes ne sont pas trop souvent mais le
truc le plus compliqué c'est
l'abstention quoique cette fois la règle
abstention additionnel causés par des
canaux mène aussi incompréhensible et
erratique que qu'on avait c'est quand
même très très très me semble t'il très
risqué et c'est vrai que spontanément de
façon intuitive
au départ on disait avant les personnes
âgées vont moins voté donc que ça va
être pas bon pour les républicains et
pour plutôt en marche parce que c'est
les bulles et les gens plus âgés ont
peur bon là dessus on a des sondages qui
disent le contraire qui vise à banon les
finalement les gens plus âgés de dix
nouveaux votes sont votés et puis qu'est
ce que c'est que ces histoires cette
cause cette épidémie qu'on n'est pas et
les jeunes
al'inverse semble-t-il l'abstention
serait plutôt du côté des jeunes et des
partis plus tôt
aux deux extrêmes ainsi tueuse extrêmes
que sont le front national d'un côté et
france a soumises de l'autre
c'est ce que nous dit ce sondage bon je
dis faut quand même se méfier
l'abstention on hâte après très très
bien après après on comprend tout mais
avant on sait jamais georges votre point
de vue sur la mer l'abstention c'est
l'art du médecin légiste effectivement
je suis on ne retienne comme punch line
sur le sûr très bien c'est l'art du
médecin légiste quelqu'un il ya deux
personnes en france et monsieur
castanéens monsieur alain minc
quand ils disent quelque chose une forte
politique soit exactement contrat qui se
produisent que ce soit en économie au
maintien de l'ordre au sol qui a des
politiques c'est julien et donc mais bon
réseau en dehors d'eux
l'humour on peut se demander ce qui peut
ce qui se passera au second tour si
effectivement il ya une courbe
exponentielle c'est-à-dire un doublement
des cas le premier tour se fera le
deuxième on peut se retrouver une
situation très compliquée on aura fait
un premier tour un pas deuxième tour
parce qu'on peut se retrouver ya pas de
raison les italiens et les italiens sont
pas plus cons que les français et peut
se retrouver dans une situation un peu
un peu identique mais si les élections
se passent oui je pense qu'il y aura un
très gros score du candidat coronavirus
et que vu ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
que on n'est pas très bien représentés
vers les coûts les grands courants de la
pensée politique française sont pas
tellement représenté 1 surtout un qui
représenté par les trois principaux
candidats
mais il n'ya pas match mais je préparais
à windhoek son pari je pense qu'il ya
une ou deux mais si c'est dans le reste
de la france
oui il y aura un effet corps à la
violence d'autant plus que les personnes
âgées sont consignées dans les ehpad
ils ont nommé le real peut elle peuvent
elles peuvent voter par procuration
quand même oui c'est toujours été
organisée c'est compliqué à réaliser
il ya des gens pour leur dire ya des
agents qui les agents il s'agira dans
les épaules il ya des agents qui ont
passé mais tout ça il sait bien que
c'est un effet ça complexifie visite
voilà il y aura des 900 compliqué moi je
pense que les électeurs d'anne hidalgo
sont plus sensibles au corona les russes
moi si j'étais eux je me ferais rien on
verra ça justement sera en direct
complètement
décimé la bidée par le coronavirus
normalement on sera en direct dimanche
prochain pour vous donner des résultats
dans l'addition spécial qu'on aura avec
public sénat et la chaîne parlementaire
je vais voter dans ma cambrousse natale
pour faire barrage à leurs masques et
dix citoyens donc il ya ce masque et
c'est bien il a amassé déjeuner je ne
sais pas il pourra masquer allée dans le
bureau de vote est allé aussi pour dire
qu'il faut être tolérant vis à vis des
masques dans les bureaux de vote ce qui
constitue quand même une exception au
rassemblement au sens de la médecine
comme chacun sait petit cri sa 4è décide
ce qu'est un rassemblement de ce que
date n'est pas simplement on n'a pas
posé la question s'il fallait maintenir
ou pas le premier tour ajoute je vous
promets on l'a on imposera d'ici la fin
de la semaine
en attendant demande comment les choses
évoluent merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
au tour de charlotte darche a très vite
sur figaro live
[Musique]